[Applause]
yes this is real hope this is what we
are seeing right now this is the hope
the people this is a movement with
millions upon millions of people telling
world leaders to act on a science and we
are demanding safe future for everyone
and that is not something you can
continue to ignore it is we young people
and future generations who are going to
suffer the most from the climates and
ecological crisis it should not be up to
us to take the responsibility
but since the leaders are behaving like
children then we have no other choice
[Applause]
[Music]
the older generations are failing us and
the political leaders are failing us but
we will be watching and holding them
accountable we will make sure they will
not get away with continuing like now
because we as young people are tired of
constantly being betrayed supposed to
work for all greater good we are here
because we care about the future about
what we one day will leave after us and
the political leaders can't seem to
think beyond the next election and that
needs to come to an end
[Applause]
for well over a year young people from
all around the world have been striking
from school every Friday demanding world
leaders to take this responsibility and
to unite behind the science they have
not done that the people in power
continue to ignore us and to ignore the
current best available science how dare
they
[Applause]
how dare they leave this mess for their
own children to clean up and so that
they are doing enough when the politics
needed are still nowhere in sight
how dare they ignore the countless of
people all around the world who are
suffering and dying today because of the
climate and ecological crisis and the
ecosystems that are being destroyed they
are indeed not mature enough to tell it
like it is
we still have this in our own pants but
to do our best is no longer good enough
we all need to do the seemingly
impossible we didn't start school
striking because we wanted to we didn't
do it because we wanted to gain
attention or because it was fun we did
it because someone needs to do something
to wait for someone else to do something
nothing is too small to make a
difference
never forget that
every Friday for as long as it takes
the next big Global Strike is November
27 29 to go on for a very long time
unfortunately but there will not stop us
we are rising that we will not back down
[Applause]
we will not beg the people in power to
care and to act because they have
ignored us in the past and they will
ignore us again we will instead tell
them that if they will do it that we
will the world is waking up and we are
the change
[Applause]
thank you once again so much and
continue the fight
[Applause]
I didn't really hear you guys deployers
exciting to hear
but that was beautiful I would really
have shivers they are like chills all
over the place he is beautiful thank you
so much you're gonna thank you for being
a warrior thank you for being a land
defender and a water protector
[Applause]